of the desert and all of its rock style
glam good day las vegas starts
right now live this is good day las
vegas
the valley's news leader six o'clock
here it is a wednesday morning we thank
you very much for joining us from our
own palatial
abode channel a broadcasting good
morning alex good morning everybody
it doesn't quite compare with where
bianca is but it's not bad
no you know uh i think it's a little
less freezing where bianca is we're all
trying to stay warm in here
but hopefully you're doing well this
morning it is a wednesday it is super
windy out there
and we have sherry swenson back with us
today welcome back sheri
good morning everybody thank you so much
happy a windy wednesday for sure
it is so windy even our shot of a high
roller looking out to the east
is bouncing around this morning we've
had gusts to 40 miles an hour in
quite a few locations overnight
sustained winds at 20 plus
so that's the constant wind that you've
heard beating against the windows and
shaking the trees around all night
temperatures in the upper 40s and low
50s but these northwest winds
are feeling much cooler than that so i
would grab some long sleeves a jacket
a coat whatever you need this morning
we'll get into the 50s through the
morning hours keeping these northwest
winds
still gusting to maybe 30 miles an hour
until we get to noon things will start
to back off a little bit
we should have a lot of sunshine out
there just a few patchy morning clouds
low 60s by about noontime and then the
afternoon into the upper 60s a little
cooler
than normal good sunshine through the
afternoon and much
quieter winds as we get through the
later part of the day
so oh my goodness we just need a break
from these winds
spring is living up to its reputation
for sure in 601
hopping on the roads need to know what
the commute's like let's check in with
nate this morning good morning nate good
morning sheri and welcome back so the
wind is the biggest factor and if that's
all we have to deal with i think that's
okay we are starting to see some
crowding here stop on the i-15 out of
the spaghetti bowl
we'll keep a camera on that if something
does develop we'll certainly let you
know
also maybe some busy nests on the 95
between say valley view and decatur
as you're heading out towards the
rainbow curve meanwhile wind is the big
story all over town you got to watch for
debris in fact we're getting reports of
some debris
up on the northern 215 beltway around
aliante we'll get a camera up there in
just a moment
first one let you know about the ramp
being back open now north 95 to the
eastbound northern 215 beltway but it
will be shut down again tonight from 8
p.m till 5 for all the work going on
there
this camera too has been bouncing around
a little bit but the traffic itself is
pretty quiet at this hour
john nate thank you it is now 602. this
morning
friends and family are remembering the
victims of monday's mass
shooting at a colorado supermarket the
10 victims range in age from 20
to 65 years old you see them there on
your screen one of the victims
a boulder police officer named eric
talley he was the first on the scene
a memorial for all of the victims has
grown outside the police headquarters
to show respect and care
to someone who i may not have known
but for the briefest moments of time was
there
one of the victims 49 year old trollona
barteep bartowick
she had recently become engaged and her
cousin is heartbroken
it's just really sad that she's gone
it's unbelievable
she had the biggest heart she's the most
loving person i've ever met in my life
and this is so devastating
the suspect is 21 year old ahmad alissa
he faces 10 counts of first degree
murder and he's scheduled to appear in
court tomorrow
president biden meanwhile has called on
congress to reinstitute a ban on assault
weapons in large capacity magazines
earlier this month house democrats did
pass two bills
expanding background checks but in a
senate committee hearing on gun control
yesterday republicans showed no sign of
crossing the aisle on this
issue alex the one october memorial
committee will meet later this morning
to discuss plans to create a permanent
tribute
they will release the results of a
recent online survey and discuss
public input they're working to create
something that is separate from the
healing garden downtown
it will honor the victims survivors and
the first responders of the 2017
massacre
that meeting is taking place this
morning at nine o'clock it will be
streamed online
speaking of registration is now open for
this year's vegas strong 5k
it is set to be in person this year on
sunday october 3rd
it is usually downtown but will be at
floyd land park this year
cobit protocol will be in place you will
have to wear a mask in social distance
early bird registration is 30 right now
runs through next wednesday
after that the price goes up until the
day of the event 100
of the proceeds go to one october
related funds like the resiliency center
and the healing garden nate 605 now on
your wednesday
today is a special day we're calling it
giving day and we're teaming up with the
red cross
to host a blood drive giving blood is
crucial
donations save lives and our hector me
he is there with a look at
what we're doing today and why it's so
important
hector hey there nate good morning
so important we never know when we might
need that blood ourselves right and
right now there are people in emergency
rooms
needing that life saving blood in fact
every two seconds someone needs a blood
donation
we're at the headquarters picking up a
couple of things before we head over to
the blood drive later on this morning
i want to introduce alan disk and he is
the executive director here at the
american red cross of southern nevada
huge huge day ahead of us good morning
sir yeah good morning and thanks for uh
letting us share this important day
tell us about the uh today so we cannot
donate blood but also
during the pandemic there's uh something
special we're doing
yeah so at the red cross we're always
responding to disasters and helping
people that are in need
and we're always getting the question
what can we do as we come out of this
pandemic
leave behind a disaster season that was
epic um
and what i say is you can volunteer your
time and contribute disaster relief but
most importantly
you can give of yourself you can give
blood
it's got to come out of your heart to go
into somebody else's and you uh
by donating blood a person that kind of
helps out in two ways tell us about that
absolutely so when you donate blood
today we can use that blood
in two different ways one is we can take
out
your plasma if you've tested positive
and have recovered
from coven 19. that is used as a
treatment one of a handful of treatments
for those that are the sickest
of kovid um and if not we can still use
your blood
in life-saving ways for people that are
in trauma people that need
cancer treatments or burn victims or
sickle cell patients
a lot of ways you can really help your
community so for those who are making
appointments today to uh donate blood
what can they do ahead of time to
prepare so i always tell people make
sure you're feeling healthy that's the
most important thing
eat something and have a lot of fluids
in your body those really help when
you're donating blood
awesome thank you very much so as i
mentioned earlier we're getting a few
things
the drive is actually happening at the
sahara west library that's located in
the west valley by grand canyon and
sahara
the hours are from 11 30 in the morning
to 4 30 in the afternoon
again sahara west library by grand
canyon sahara
and you can make an appointment by going
to a red cross redcrossblood.org
or you can give them a call at 1 800 red
cross so we're going to walk around here
again
getting a few things before we head out
we'll have another live interview still
ahead in the next half hour for now
reporting live hector mejia
8 news now back to you that is so
awesome hector and
john and i will be out there for our
news at noon but for now we'll toss
things over to alex
all right thank you both so much it is
607 and coming up after the break we
highlight another remarkable woman in
the valley
she's just really everything to me she
really is
because i would never hate it thousands
of students that can tell you
that how she's touched their lives you
will meet one woman who hit rock bottom
for years
she earned a phd and is now helping
countless others turn their lives around
it's a wonderful story we've got it for
you right after this
and silver state schools credit union
you're watching good day las vegas with
john langler
alex bacchus sheri suensk and
nate tannenbaum live on eight news
now welcome back everyone 8 news now is
continuing to highlight remarkable women
across the valley
from addiction to a devastating medical
diagnosis
shelly keller grew up with a lot of
obstacles but she is a shining example
of how the biggest challenges can become
opportunities to change your own life
and the lives of others dr
shelly keller has spent 15 years at the
college of southern nevada
it's a place she never imagined she
could be
i walked into that campus and it changed
my life
shelly was born in ohio she experienced
trauma as a child
and remembers having her first drink at
six years old
just a sip you know when i tasted it i
immediately
thought oh this this helps me feel
better by the time she was 13
shelley was drinking heavily she was
also having major stomach issues
had surgery then received devastating
news
they're telling me i can't have children
and that devastated me
shelley dropped out of high school
continued drinking and became
addicted to meth for 15 years that was
the hardest thing i
ever did was to stop drinking
i i went to that rehab but that wasn't
the first rehab i went to
she kept fighting in 2006 shelley was
figuring out her next steps
and a counselor asked if she thought
about community college
shelley walked onto the csn campus and
with guidance
and encouragement enrolled as a student
it gave me hope
it gave me self-worth it connected me to
people that
lived different ways shelly went on to
unlv where she's earned a ph.d
she is the first in her family to
graduate college
but shelley wanted to return to csn she
was hired as a public speaking professor
she is now the director for the centers
for academic success
her job is helping students achieve
their dreams
it's the most remarkable experience to
tell you the truth is to
be giving back barbara iarza's dream was
college
at 40 years old a single mom of six and
a high school dropout
her dream seemed out of reach been
through about the worst of the worst
so homeless at a woman's shelter
lost both my parents she went to student
orientation at csn and met dr
shelly keller her first day basically
just bawled my eyes out and told her my
story and how desperate i was
and having no idea that she was the
perfect person
in the perfect position shelly helped
barbara with a job
child care and most importantly
encouragement
barbara since landed a full ride to unlv
where she's earned a bachelor's
in psychology she's just really
everything to me
she really is because i would never hate
it
thousands of students that can tell you
that how she's touched their lives
while she succeeded professionally
shelley still dreamt of having her own
family
she and her husband became foster
parents and 14 years ago
they adopted their two children emma and
joseph
both were impacted by drugs and alcohol
and i knew
that i would have something to offer
those kids
they are the best kids they're just
they're remarkable
if you went back to being 13 and
could see you right now
would you ever believe that that
question will make me cry
because no no i was so
[Music]
i had lost hope as a child
shelly has been sober since 2010 and her
mission to help others
is far from over some of the hardest
things you go through
in the end you see so much meaning if
you just look for it
isn't she remarkable and so is barbara
they both were
incredible shelley by the way now
credits counseling for
helping her turn her life around and get
this she just went back to school to
become a counselor herself and if that's
not all
she's also just started a non-profit
it's called the nevada institute
for mental health and addiction and man
it was just such an honor to meet her
you guys she is so
remarkable and has helped so many people
here in the valley she's so humble too
of everything she's accomplished wow
what an amazing woman
both amazing women yeah great story
well let's switch to housing now you
know we talked so much about the housing
market john
and how it vegas is red hot right now
realtors say that
people moving from all over the country
is helping to drive the market
multiple offers on every home increasing
the demand
surprisingly despite the pandemic sherry
luxury homes are even in
higher demand right now here's one
that's been called by the folks involved
the jewel of the desert it is one of the
most expensive properties
in the valley it's worth just a measly
18 million dollars sherry
the home is located in the south valley
the mcdonald highlands neighborhood and
has
stunning views of the strip it has not
one but two
pools complete with seven waterfalls of
its own
a chef's kitchen cocktail bar movie
theater
and a game room john it is a remarkable
house it is a remarkable housing market
with more snazzy details let's get right
to bianca holman and what she has
determined as the new henderson bureau
for eight news now bianca good morning
to
yeah i think i'm just going to move in
you know they can just send my clothes
here
and i'll take just the downstairs suite
but we are inside of the
living space the living room the kitchen
area the grand entrance here
and to tell us more about this property
i'm joined by amelia king
keen so tell us how is the housing
market so far in las vegas oh my gosh
it is so hot right now if there is like
a gauge
and the needle is all the way to the
right and it's clanging it's amazing
for example the luxury segment uh used
to be a small cycle
of our uh real estate division but in
the last year sales in the luxury
segment have gone up 84
just in one year and there's multiple
offers even for
you know 18 million not everybody has 18
million in the bank
uh but you know even for homes like this
there's a buyer for every property i
always say
yeah and who designed this space because
we've been able to go to the several
different rooms
and it is amazing we've only shown you a
fraction but we have a very special
designer that has created the space she
is amazing her name is stephanie stiles
and she is a luxury designer
and i actually call her the house
whisperer she is amazing
has created this property from the
beginning from
construction she just doesn't put a
pillow on a couch or a painting on the
wall she's amazing
yeah well we've learned so much and
guess what we're going to head over and
chat
with uh mrs stephanie styles so thank
you so much for
welcoming us here and showing us the
intricate designs
and you are a true professional of
luxury designing homes and tell us again
about this table about this kitchen tell
us about it all
um okay so let's start with the dining
room table i knew that i wanted
it to light up i just wasn't quite sure
how so we
made sure that we had the electrical in
the floor and then i got with one of my
companies and we created
a chandelier under the table now if you
look above the table those are the exact
same
chandeliers above it just they have
shades on them
so every single room is special and you
have to create it special
so even though they all have their own
identity the overall
project flows seamlessly inside and out
room to room
yeah and you were telling me about these
floors chad take a look at these floors
i know we're in the kitchen
these floors are special they are
roberto valley who knew roberto
made flooring but he does i created the
grid system because the floor is so big
that you need to break it up and create
pattern my ode to roberto cavalli is the
custom
backsplash over the range it's from a
company called bazatza
overseas and we created the cheetah
print which is roberta cavalli's
uh look that's his his brand it's the
classic everyone recognizes that so
now you don't just do this for everybody
but can people get in touch with you and
can you do this for somebody you know
they have a mansion that's being built
right now and they need someone like you
right
absolutely that's what i'm here for
um i love doing design and i am
fortunate that i get to do it
every day so i'm the designer that you
call
when you've got you know renovations
happening um you gotta just tear it all
out
we're starting fresh with construction
because i love picking the faucets
i love picking the sinks i love creating
the tile details and designs
so i'm the one that's start to finish
i'm usually one of the first ones on the
job and the last one to leave the job
all right well thank you so much
stephanie for welcoming us in i mean it
just
has been jaw dropping since we arrived
right at the entrance
all the way through through the home
can't wait to see the sun rise because
we haven't gotten to see outside yet but
guess what be sure
go on facebook yeah get ready to go on
facebook because we're going to go
facebook live when the sun gets up
and she's going to show us the whole the
the pool area and
there's a wine cave it's the one cave no
one else has this no one else has it the
wine cave i can't wait to show you all
on facebook live send it back to you
guys in the studio
oh wow we're going to go spelunking in
the wine cave i can't wait
so it's a fixer-upper right is that what
that is i doubt it
it's a renault it's a renault project
wow what a house my goodness
also if that's our new bureau uh sorry
all but i'm gonna be the new henderson
reporter
just look at my house and figure out how
to make it five thousand square feet
bigger
yeah just by decorating decorating a lot
of mirrors
wow that is
assignment gorgeous all right should we
talk about the weather although i'd love
to talk about this for the next 40
minutes
lifestyles of the rich and the famous
right
all right we're looking outside guys
we've got a lot of wind blowing in and
chances are you're gonna have to do some
cleanup
around your own casa and hacienda today
because we've had those winds 30 40
miles an hour
in the overnight hours and they're still
blowing and pretty blustery out there
sustained right now at 17 at the airport
but they were pretty much
20 25 sustained just seeing this much of
a difference as we're getting closer to
daybreak which is 6 38 by the way
6 56 is the sun set so we're in our
first week of spring spring living up to
its reputation of being windy
even though we started the winds way
back in about mid winter
60 60 plus mile per hour winds possible
along the river today that those are
very isolated gusts
we'll talk about the wind advisory in
place red rock has had near 50 mile an
hour winds overnight powell canyon 40
plus
north las vegas and mccarran both over
35 mile an hour winds just a trace of
rain officially yesterday
with those showers we're still behind
for the year we need
more rain and we have another system
that's going to drop in
by tomorrow so four inches of snow up in
the mountain at lee canyon that's great
news but
just some very minor reports of rain as
far as measurable rain in the northwest
valley
the wind is on the backside of this
system which is already over
in the four corners area bringing snow
to albuquerque up to denver
here's the wind advisory for the lake
generally 45 plus mile an hour winds but
again some very isolated gusts
could bring those to 50 to 60 through
the morning and afternoon hours to 3
o'clock so
the next system already on its way
dropping into the pacific northwest
we'll get clouds tonight southwest
breezes tomorrow and maybe a chance for
some scattered showers around as well
enjoy the sun we'll get the break in the
winds this afternoon
and then southwest breezes return
tomorrow we'll stay extra cool too for a
few days
but the weekend we pop right back into
some extra warm mid to upper 70s
even 80s on monday before we finish
march next week
it's 6 22 let's get to nate on the roads
so far so good we are seeing some
bunching up a little bit now northland
on the 95 515 into the spaghetti bowl
southbound 15 out of the spaghetti bowl
no crashes it's just a little bit
crowded wind is the big story in fact
we had a report of some debris up on the
northern 215 beltway around
aliante if there was something there
it's probably blown away the traffic
there is moving along in pretty good
shape
here we have a junior traffic buddy
teaching moment what's driving you crazy
is next on good day lost
tough as nails on eight news now
6 26 city wednesday morning what's
driving you crazy hey we're dropping
some traffic
lingo from an ordinary ramp closure so
the gist of a recent ndot press release
the closure of the southbound i-11 on
and off ramps at wagon wheel started a
couple of nights ago
scheduled to run from 8pm to 5am nightly
until april 8th but
it's the work that's being done that
provides a tiny peek into the wide world
of traffic besides just
cars moving around ndot says the
temporary closures are needed for
constructing
rip wrap drainage channels alongside the
interchange now you've probably driven
by many examples of
rip rap without knowing oh that's what
it's called wikipedia says
rip-rap is human-placed rock or other
material that rip-raps are used to armor
shorelines and stream beds and bridge
abutments against erosion you probably
never stop to think about it other than
maybe hey
nice rocks by this side of the road but
let me tell you rip-rap is a serious
business
they don't just toss those rocks out
there i found dozens of 100 page
documents with diagrams crazy math
equations
rip rap who knew i'll be putting some of
those links on the online version of
this story at eight newsnow dot com
click traffic then driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put
down the phone
if there's something driving you crazy
email me traffic eight eight news now
dot com